and sadly that child a four-year-old boy  has died following a serious medical  incident at the longleat center Park's  Resort in Wiltshire  police and ambulances were called to the  site shortly after 11 o'clock this  morning  Center Parks confirmed that the incident  took place in the subtropical swimming  Paradise at the company's longleat  Forest Resort a Wiltshire police  statement said sadly it's been confirmed  that a four-year-old boy has died  following an incident this is not being  treated as suspicious and in the last  few minutes we've just had this  statement from Center Parks we are  deeply saddened by the tragic news that  a young guest has passed away at  longleat Forest today we are offering  our support to the family and to our  employees Who provided immediate  assistance  our thoughts remain with the family at  this very difficult time